hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bad dream comer now I
played the bad dream series years ago
but this is the full release of the game
it actually traverses the same locations
as the other ones or so I've been told
but going back to them and I don't know
the story of this I barely knew the
story in the first one they were loosely
connected but they were connected
because it all related to you being in a
coma and so here we stand at the gates
of this new game fully released on Steam
and I have no idea what's in store but
if you guys remember bad dream it was a
really really cool series sweet dreams
who's kissing me good night where is my
bedtime story okay I'll just drift off
into blackness then that's fine chapter
one the bridge now if you remember the
ending of the first series of games took
place on a bridge and I'm pretty sure it
seems the same but trust me this is
completely different
do I really want to punch that crow why
do I want to punch this bird never mind
that's exactly what I did I don't know
why I did that but that's what happened
those birds need any help visit us we
will help you for free no catch I'm sure
they're so weird okay bye buddy
Oh weather heavy storm you goddamn liar
Bridge is closed
oh you goddamn liar that's weird whoa
found something
look nut killed Birds
hello hi why why would you do that so
the thing about this game is like
there's a lot of very minut
did you hear about the crazed bird
puncher I'll punch you right in your
bird buttons go up the bridge I did what
BAM I'm crazy I'm so sorry oh I'm so
sorry about that
that's glue SHhhh oh good I got that
what's that gonna do controller active
great what does that do
why can't he wake up good question stop
doing that you got out a reason for that
well hello again Birds
oh well that's gone well that's gone
rake this goddamn bridge Oh syrup it to
hell right in the middle of the bridge
oh hi Spidey yeah okay go to your pit of
hell go back what are we looking at here
do I need to look at stuff missing nurse
where is she I don't know hey nurse oh
god it was an accident I swear
it was with the pit of hell like what
are we doing over there oops
welp I'm destroying this goddamn bridge
well that's so cool but there's so many
minut things in the environment to click
on such an exploration game well I got
keys oops no that's not what I wanted to
do urghhh boink I feel bad about this I
can't reach you yeah you're lucky you're
across that bridge you think you can
mess with me huh what's this lost sit
our Hospital alrighty then if you saw so
I did not have to punch all those birds
I realized that now I did not have to
bunch those birds I am an [ __ ]
oh well it's getting darker why is it
getting darker oh wait the remote for
this car there we go WEEE
ooh there we go oh no got in a car
accident wait what did then then did
that actually have repercussions why is
it getting darker over there hey I saw
you god dammit I saw you status Oh
status birds hate you yes they do I've
got blood on my hands and Birds oh I've
already ruined it for the bad end I'm
already gonna get the bad and I didn't
even know oh well [ __ ] buckle me oh
my god I've done wrong I didn't want to
punch the birds what's gonna happen me
oh oh [ __ ] hi oh that is [ __ ] Oh
oh well I guess I can unlock this
crowbar sure that makes sense so I have
a full sized crowbar from that made
should I go back and redo it I feel like
I should I feel like I have to at this
point I have to do this again I'll be
right back though I'll be right back
good finger I check that status or are
you Birds I'm not gonna punch you I
swear to God
I see you over there okay hello again I
don't have blood on my hands now so I
won't touch your blood all right
oh thank you for this okay so now that I
got the crowbar and now that my endings
are still available to me I'm gonna
crowbar this not kill no Birds why did I
do that
Oh a bridge I can use that to bridge the
gap that seems precarious but I'm gonna
go for we're good
everything's fine who just farted
alright you don't need to make fun of me
gonna go forward
oh you
did somebody lose their baby that seems
weird but okay okay so there's some
electrical poles oh oh that's so cool
that's such a minor detail but I
appreciate it so much look the way the
Lightning goes to my oh my little hero
oh that's so good oh that's good stuff
okay anyway we got to get through this
which means that we gotta Jam this
crowbar in there I don't know what we
got to do oh wait okay so there needs to
be something connecting that to each
other so I need like a piece of iron or
something like that right I gotcha
okay we're again this baby little
concern oh hi baby I saw that bag move
but okay oh my god I gotta go back okay
Elyse it's got me here oh my god I did
not want to smash that baby why is her
baby here this game is messing with my
brain oh this game is oh so you can get
a wire from that baby maybe I could
there we go that's a much better option
oh that's a much better hi baby could
you stop staring at me like that because
my god baby that is not okay could you
just stop staring at me oh my god baby
oh well that's well I'm gonna punch a
bird in anger what the hell do I do now
why does this goddamn why's it getting
darker oh my god over here over here oh
hi hello
Oh you looking for your crowbar
I wasn't give me something oh my god
will left my crowbar here give me
something in return do you want a bottle
didn't who did you get that oh I
probably shouldn't do that oh well left
my crowbar there okay that's so weird
I love this games the attention to
detail that's really really cool oh well
it's like that was gonna happen anyway I
would have just broken it alright anyway
I guess I'll just me an oar where'd this
come from why is there a pickle rubber
duct okay okay that's weird but I'll
deal I'll say oh why you good man you
blind man with two toes sticking out do
you have some change I do there you are
thank you so much have a nice day I will
you too take care Oh what is that I have
a good heart
Oh what else what I have done just
punched him like all the birds I punched
[Laughter]
[Music]
man that's so weird
that's so weird oh that's so weird
but anyway that's chapter one complete
now I don't know how many chapters are
in this game but knowing the first
series I believe it was broken up into
six parts so the next one is the
hospital so we're gonna pick it up right
there I'm gonna try to maintain my good
status but I don't know how easy that's
gonna be so thank you everybody so much
for watching I'll get to this game more
real soon
so let me know what you think down the
comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
[Music]